¿Alguna vez se han preguntado cómo secuenciamos
el ADN? Bueno, echemos un vistazo rápido a
la secuenciación de ADN. Vamos a dividir la
secuenciación de ADN en tres pasos diferentes:
el primer paso es tomar la muestra de ADN que nos
interesa secuenciar y usar PCR para amplificar
la muestra. Al utilizar la PCR para amplificar la
muestra podemos generar muchos fragmentos de ADN.
Lo siguiente que hacemos normalmente en la PCR
es agregar nucleótidos. Debemos darle a la cadena
en crecimiento el sustrato desde el cual puede
crecer, normalmente se agregan desoxinucleótidos
regulares y se parecen a esto: tenemos un grupo OH
aquí, tenemos un grupo H aquí, tenemos una base,
luego tenemos un grupo de carbono y oxígeno
hidrógeno. Así es como se ve un nucleótido normal,
pero intercalado en la PCR, lo que también
deseamos es agregar algo que se conoce como
didesoxinucleótido. Un didesoxinucleótido
se parece a esto, básicamente es lo mismo,
pero sólo tiene un hidrógeno aquí, por lo que
se elimina este oxígeno. Y lo que hace es que,
si este didesoxinucleótido, que podemos abreviar
como ddNTP, si esto se incorpora a la cadena en
crecimiento, ya que no hay grupo de oxígeno aquí,
la cadena ya no puede alargarse, básicamente
tenemos la terminación de alargamiento de cadena,
tan pronto como este ddNTP se incorpora. Lo que
podemos hacer es marcar de manera fluorescente
los diferentes didesoxinucleótidos. Por ejemplo,
tenemos cuatro opciones distintas: podemos
etiquetar todas las ges azules, podemos etiquetar
todas las as rojas, todas las tes verdes y todas
las ces anaranjadas. Lo que tenemos son estos
didesoxinucleótidos con diferentes marcadores
fluorescentes que se incorporan a la cadena en
crecimiento y dado que la PCR puede amplificarse
creando millones y millones de fragmentos de ADN,
tendremos cadenas de diferentes longitudes.
Sólo veamos un ejemplo. Imaginemos que tenemos
un nucleótido incorporado aquí, un nucleótido
normal, y luego otro incorporado aquí y luego
al azar, de repente tenemos un didesoxinucleótido
incorporado aquí y esto detendría el alargamiento
de la cadena, entonces tendríamos una cadena de
ADN con sólo 4 nucleótidos de largo. Y después
de otra ronda de PCR podríamos tener 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, sólo está creciendo, está creciendo y de
repente ¿qué pasó? Tenemos un didesoxinucleótido
incorporado. Básicamente hacemos esto y después de
obtener millones de muestras, finalmente podremos
tener algo así. Quizá tengamos sólo un nucleótido
regular y un didesoxinucleótido incorporado, o
quizá tengamos, digamos dos, entonces tendremos
dos y luego tendremos este incorporado. Lo que
podemos ver es que hay cadenas que se están
alargando y que diferentes cadenas terminan en
diferentes puntos por un didesoxinucleótido. Y,
entonces, el siguiente paso es usar electroforesis
en gel para separar las cadenas por tamaño,
así que cuando corremos todos los diferentes
fragmentos en un gel, éste los separará por
tamaño y luego podemos hacer que una computadora
analice todas las etiquetas fluorescentes, y si ve
aquí esta luz fluorescente, entonces sabe que el
segundo nucleótido en la secuencia es una G, por
lo que dirá G; y luego verá aquí, dirá "Está bien,
esta es una C"; luego verá aquí, dirá que tenemos
otra G, y así sucesivamente. Y la computadora, al
leer estas etiquetas fluorescentes, puede darnos
una secuencia de ADN. Y esto es una descripción
general de cómo funciona la secuenciación de ADN.